if you have been dreaming of having a
balcony Garden Oasis here are five tips
to help you successfully care for plants
in containers growing
Joy hi plant friends I'm Maria your new
best plant friend and I'm here to help
you care for plant successfully but most
importantly grow Joy while doing so and
there is nothing more joyful than
sitting on your balcony with a mocktail
or a cocktail at dusk enjoying scented
herbs blow in the wind maybe some cut
flowers I've been balcony gardening for
the last four or five years the first
balcony I gardened on was 9 Square ft in
New York City it was basically this big
now I am lucky enough to have this epic
balcony that's about 150 square feet
that I grow most of my fruits and
vegetables over the summer I have
learned a lot in these four years so I
wanted to go over my top five tips to
help you have a successful first year or
maybe second year gardening tip number
one is going to be to utilize your
vertical space a lot of balconies you
really don't have that much space right
so use every inch that you have as you
see I'm using my balcony railing in two
different ways I have these hanging
planters that I'm planting on and I also
am actually using it as a trellis so I
have little cucumbers here that will
grow and start trellising across the
balcony also if you don't have a balcony
railing that is slatted like this that
you can actually use as a trellis make
sure that you use trellises so I'm
planting way more food in this one
container because I have a trellis that
the center plant is going to grow up
then I can utilize the side space so it
doesn't like Bush out and it actually
grows up and you just can get more bang
for your buck out of one container tip
number two if you're growing in
containers they're going to dry out
faster so you need to understand how
you're going to sustainably water all of
your plants throughout your summer when
you have travel involved right who
doesn't have a million weddings to
attend this summer so you can do that in
a couple of different ways if you you
could either do self-watering Planters
these are self-watering Planters they
have a watering Reservoir you fill them
up with a hose and then these can go
like one or two weeks without having to
water the plants over and over and over
again it's great for if you travel if
you're not going to do that here's a
watering hack that I do when I water my
grow bags grow bags particularly are
amazing for container gardening but they
do dry out faster than any other
container out there have two watering
cans usually if you have more than one
container it's helpful to have one
watering can that you're watering in
this will fill up in the sink as you're
watering and then you can swap it out
it'll just make watering less time
consuming if you have two also these
aren't fancy watering cans I literally
bought this at the dollar store a couple
of days ago tip number three intensive
plant if you want to grow a kitchen herb
garden on your balcony a lot of people
that's the Gateway into gardening you
have a little balcony with a little bit
of sun you want to grow some herbs
there's nothing better than cutting
chives and scrambling them into your
eggs that day or or harvesting fresh cut
basil for you know a little garnish or
making your own pesto with so if you are
going to have a kitchen herb garden you
can plant your herbs pretty close
together it's called intensive planting
because you're going to be constantly
harvesting from them you're basically
pring the plant on a weekly basis so you
don't need to listen to the guidelines
on on the plant tag so in this one
container I have oregano parsley
cilantro rosemary thyme Sage micro dorf
Tomatoes I have lettuces on the outside
I am using every square inch of this
planter to get the largest yield of
Edibles that I can because when you're
on a balcony you got to make use of your
space right number four be mindful of
the varieties that you choose when
balcony and container gardening I have
an entire salad worth of food in this
one container because I've chosen micro
dwarf varieties when you're at the
Garden Center it's either going to say
dwarf variety patio variety or container
variety those are plants that have been
intentionally br to have be more smaller
and compact so you can grow them in
small spaces as an example this is the
kitchen minis red velvet micro dworf
tomato it's only going to get like 12
Ines tall maybe this big I'll get a ton
of tomatoes off this plant but it's just
going to be super small in here I'm
growing a quick snack cucumber so it's a
Vine it's going to climb up the Trella
so it's not going to take up a lot of
space it's going to grow mini cucumbers
right so these are all mini plants I
have a mini um bell pepper plant the
kitchen mini fresh by spites orange
sweet pepper and then I also am growing
Tom Thumb lettuce which is like a more
compact lettuce so I have a ton of
plants in here and the reason why I can
plant them all together is because
they're all micro dorf patio varieties
so they're going to take up less space
Also if you want to grow flowers you
definitely should if you're trying to
grow food right because if tomatoes need
pollinators to make sure that you get a
lot of beautiful fruit so I have small
edible flowers like these violas also if
you're looking at the Garden Center make
sure sometimes if you get a Zenia for
example it'll be a container Zenia or a
patio Zenia or you can just look at the
tag to see how tall the plant gets if
you're trying to grow a flower I
wouldn't grow a flower that gets over
like 12 or 16 inches tall Zenia is a
great example you can buy a Zenia that
can get four feet tall or you could buy
a Zenia that can get 10 Ines tall so
read the packet before you buy this
isn't a packet this is a plant card and
last but not least my find the shade
that your balcony railing or other
balconies around you can provide in my
first apartment in New York City when I
had that tiny balcony I mentioned it was
an apartment balcony there was a balcony
on top of us a balcony below us so we
were actually shaded also understand
your exposure so this balcony this uh
this is South the the sun rises in the
East sets in the west so we get really
strong Western Light um these plants
pretty much get direct sunlight for
eight hours a day but if you have a
balcony that faces the north it's going
to be a lower light situation right so
you need to see do I have unobstructed
views of the Sun or do I have a balcony
or another building blocking the Sun for
my plants and then also what is the
railing doing to my plants so if you see
this this is an elevated garden so it's
amazing because this railing is never
going to cast shade on this planter
however my grow bags over here might get
some shade because at the point where
the sun is over there they're going to
be in a little bit of a shadow so be
mindful of the exposure of your balcony
and then the shade that other elements
in your environment might be providing
whether it's a building next to you
whether it's a balcony railing whether
it's balconies above or next to you
everybody's balcony lighting is
definitely a unique snowflake so you're
going to have to do a little bit of
sleuthing to make sure that you set
yourself up for success and a general
rule of thumb is most edible plants need
about 6 to8 hours of direct sunlight you
can get away if you don't have that much
you can probably try growing lettuces
and some tender herbs and be okay but
that's also something a quick Google can
answer for you one bonus tip enjoy your
balcony Garden sometimes this can get
very stressful right I'm giving you
these tips to set you up for success but
also some of the best lessons you can
learn about growing from plants come
from plant plays I always try and grow
something I've never grown before every
single year to continue expanding my
knowledge and enjoy yourself enjoy the
aromatic herbs that you're growing enjoy
the the beautiful blooms that you're
growing I hope all of these tips help
set you up to have a restorative Oasis
amidst your probably busy Urban
environment that you're living in and
that this summer whatever you grow you
keep growing Joy